- [Instructor] A student
builds a circuit with a battery
and two light bulbs in series.
Then the student builds
a second circuit with two
light bulbs in parallel.
Which battery runs out of power first?
Assume all bulbs have equal resistance.
Assume both batteries have
equal electrical potential.
All right, so let's just think about this
before we even look at the choices.
So the first scenario,
you have your battery,
positive terminal, negative terminal.
And you have two light bulbs in series.
So let's just draw it this way.
And traditional light bulbs
really are just resistors
that when a current goes through them
they get hot enough, that's
because the energy dissipated,
that they emit visible light.
So that's the first resistor,
or the first light bulb,
second one, and it goes back.
So that's the first scenario.
The second scenario looks like this.
Plus minus, where they
are in parallel.
They are in parallel.
Just like that.
And they say assume all
bulbs have equal resistance.
So could just call their
resistances R, just like that.
And we assume that both of these batteries
are, for the sake of argument, identical.
So one way to think about it is,
what is going to be the
equivalent resistance
for these circuits?
This one when you have
two resistors in series,
you could simplify, or
you could do this circuit
as you have your voltage
source, which is our battery,
and you could model it as a circuit
with one resistor where
it's resistance is two R.
If you wanna think of an
equivalent for this parallel
circuit, you have your
same voltage source,
and you could model it as
having a resistor there.
And what would this resistance be?
What is equivalent to these
two resistances in parallel?
So if we call this resistance
sub two, we know that
one over resistance sub two is equal to
one over R plus one over
R, and this is the formula
for equivalent resistance when you have
resistors in parallel.
And so this is going to
be equal to two over R.
And so if you just take the
reciprocal of this and this,
you get R two is equal to R over two.
So this is equal to R over two.
Now, what is the power
dissipated across a resistor?
We know, let me just do
this in a different color,
power dissipated across
a resistor is going to be
the voltage across the
resistor times the current
going through that resistor.
Well, we know that the
voltage across both of these
resistances is going to be the same.
So V is going to be the
same in either situation.
But what about the current?
Well we know that V is equal to IR.
Or another way to think about it is
current is equal to
voltage over resistance.
So our current in this first scenario
is going to be V over
two R, while our current
in this second scenario is
going to be V over R over two,
which is the same thing as two V over R.
So our current in this second scenario
is going to be four times as large.
So if you quadruple the
current and you have the same
voltage, well you're
gonna quadruple the power.
And so if you're quadrupling the power,
you're quadrupling the amount of energy
that's dissipated per unit of time.
And so in this second
scenario where we quadrupled
the power, we're quadrupling the energy
dissipated over time.
That battery is going
to run out a lot faster.
So they ask which battery
runs out of power first,
well that's gonna be the
batter in the circuit
with two light bulbs in parallel.
And we're done.